I thought it would be good I didn't
check it out but are you familiar with
my Channel at all yeah
we ain't gonna talk about that soft
though I promise you that it's good
can I wear a mask no I can't do masks
that's Primo
Primo is is a joint with a little bit of
uh cracking a crack in it
that's how a lot of people get started
on crack right nah you know my whole
life I heard people tell me that I will
be smoking a pipe soon
I mean I'm 54.
you know when I was a kid
crack was King and uh my uncles they
sold the heroin
and one crack at the scene where is this
New York I'm from New York City okay and
when cracker at the scene I got mentors
you know they weren't family to me but
they treated me like family and they
taught me the business
I learned how to cook crack from a man
called Dr Rock
you know what I mean he used to be he
was one of them 70s pimps and he had the
the different colored leather purse and
he had the different color leather
jacket and the sniper and he really
hated women but he had a bunch of them
and inside that purse he kept the Star
Trek Enterprise and he would put the
rock right in the middle of the round
part of the Enterprise and the two
things that came out well he smoked that
so he'd stick his thumb in one side and
hit out of it but if the chicks made
enough money he let the chicks smoke out
of the other side
here's my mentor he showed me everything
he taught me how to cook crack
he had a buddy named Simon he was a
black gorilla and Sam taught me how to
hide guns in the couch and
you know have a man at the door and
check what was going on before they came
in the house and serve him and get them
out real fast you know
no hand-to-hand sales getting money to
somebody else you give them the dope I
managed to stay out of
any kind of incarceration until I was
like 39.
you've been in the dope game for a long
time now yeah
my uncles were cooking crack one day and
we were chopping it up on plates and he
rolled the blunt with some coke in it
and he said you know what this is but I
was 12. I just want to be as big as the
big boy you know
so I lied I said yeah I know what it is
I have no idea and he goes we'll light
it and I lit that [__] and top of my
head got tight my throat got numb
top of my mouth got numb
I didn't know what the [__] that was I
couldn't feel my tongue my ears were
ringing I was like what the [__] is this
he's like pass it I was like I ain't
passing [__] to you tell me what this is
and he said this [__] you're cutting on
a plate that's what it is I was like for
real he was like yeah why you tell me
why don't why do you think I tell you to
give me all the crumbs when you're done
so that was the beginning of the end I
mean I liked it and I still like it it's
my major malfunction but I pay for it I
don't I don't [__] rob nobody still
nothing from nobody none of that [__]
but I hustle
his crack unraveled your life like it
does the a lot of the people down here
since I've been in L.A I've been okay
but yeah I lost my life I lost my life
doing covet
I did I had a chick
that was on meth
OD she's a hooker
but the mess made her
just want to [__] whether she was
getting paid or not and she wasn't
holding up her end of it and
I wasn't paying attention and before I
knew it I lost everything
but you can't keep a good [__] down
you know pretty soon I'll be signing the
lease on my new crib and
I got my Social Security and
I'll be all right
what brought you down L.A
what do you mean Why'd You Come to LA
because of her she tried to kill me like
three times
thank you
see what everybody
I know and everybody on the [__]
blade
out in Arizona we got a whole stroke
called Van Buren but
famous
pimps
come to Van Buren and [__]
pimp they hoes
if I had a dope spot on that on the
blade my grandpa had two hotels so I was
like
old school when I hit the blade
and I just got out of prison and
she was one of my brother's girls I
stole it from him I told him I was gonna
come do something to his white girls and
something nasty and he told me if you
think you can go ahead but I could I
knew that so I came back and I got her
and I thought that she was a good fit
with me but we were toxic together she
just wanted to bust nuts and after she
bust a nuts she'd go off on her little
missions
she made a lot of money but I never saw
a dime of it
what was your childhood like
I'm a twin
we came out breaching I came out first
my sister came out her feet was stuck to
my head right here that's why I got this
spot
and uh
we lived in Brooklyn
40th and fifth
nice little Brownstone we went to
private school my father was a gangster
my father was a rapper my father was a
pimp
and he didn't spend a lot of time but he
made sure we had everything we needed
you know and he couldn't spend a lot of
time we'd go to see the Harlem
Globetrotters you know and right after
the
the Fanfare and we get all our snacks
and stuff and we sit down in our seats
and we were courtside
as soon as the lights went down the show
started he'd lean over and say I gotta
go hand me a hundred dollar bills so we
could catch the cab back home Brooklyn
you take off
United Artist theater when Star Wars
came out
we had every we had so much [__] from
the snack bar we had little tables in
front of us
and we were sitting right in the front
you know on the best spots in the
theater as soon as the lights went out
and the commercials was over my father
ran over so I gotta go
give us money take off
that's that was my experience to him you
know he was a heroin addict but he was a
heroin dealer he fixed in the morning he
fixed the night sometimes he mess around
in the afternoon but he wasn't one of
them not heroin addicts he was a hype
heroine he he'd get that [__] in his
system and he started dancing around and
[__] and he'd want to play dominoes and
play poker and you know what I mean he
made money he was always about money one
thing he taught me was knowledge is
power
which you don't know can't hurt you and
in the 2000s if you ain't got your game
straight
you're gonna get [__] off
I've always had that work ethic though
if it is to be it's up to me
ain't nobody else gonna give it to me I
gotta go get it
you had your life to live all over again
would you have done anything differently
I don't know man I ain't gonna lie to
you
I think my life turned out the way it
was supposed to
I think
God
wanted me to see things that
I can't unsee
you know and
when I was 12
my parents put me out
because when I was nine
I wouldn't be a kid
they were Rough Riders they they had
motorcycles and they would go
on rallies to California I got uncles
in California that are East Bay dragons
I got uncles in Arizona that are Chosen
Few
you know and I got uncles and uh
in Louisiana I got uncles in Florida
you know but they all do drugs I've been
in 28 States
you know and I was bred for this I was I
was born to this it's part of who I am
but I can remember my parents being out
of town
and me going to my uncle and saying I
need money and he gave me you know 200
300 bucks for me and my sister
but he'd ask me how much money you want
and he'd be counting money from his
sales and he'd be big stacks of money on
the table and I told him I want that
money I want that much money
and he'd laugh and get him from the
table go in the kitchen and he'd come
back with a big old sandwich bag full of
coke and hand me that and I asked him
what am I supposed to do with this he
goes you'll figure it out
and I did I sat right there and waited
for one of his Runners to come and pay
him the money and get another bag and
when he ran off wherever he went I
followed him
when he got to the house I went in the
house he couldn't stop me he worked for
my uncle
he's backing up the dope I'm watching
him back up the door I started banging
up my dope with his bags
you know he's standing out on the porch
selling I'm standing out on the porch
next to him selling
and I started seeing how to get money
did you have anybody around you as a kid
any role models that were
taking a straight path
my brother J Whip and my brother binky
with drug dealers and parents
Marco Vicente he sold heroin
and he sold marijuana but he had a long
drugs
and uh it was attached to a bar and the
reason he had the drugstore was because
upstanding citizens could go into the
drugstore and then walk into the bar at
10 o'clock in the morning but they
couldn't be seen walking into the bar at
10 o'clock in the morning so they'd go
to the drugstore and go get drunk
so after school I would go to his bar
and he would give me a mouth full of
heroin balloons and I fill my mouth up
with Heroin balloons and then I'd run
through the drugstore and grab me a
comic book off the rack
and run to my neighborhood I used to
watch my pops Lucas
you know they get out of cars and they
walk up to me and they slide 20 bucks
into my comic book and I spit them out a
balloon
but then later on that night we go to
the whole house
he'd be in the back room checking them
for the money that they were late you
know they they were short off their
[__] quota and you could hear them
slapping the [__] out of him
you know I mean it was loud pow pow and
I'd be sitting in the front room on the
couch with the money they were short in
my front pocket and they never told on
me because they want to do it again
tomorrow
so I learned back then
they gonna come see that that dope sack
before they go see that pimping every
time
so I'd rather pimp the white girl in my
pocket didn't [__] be sweating some
chicken yelling at her and all that it's
a waste of time
what's your what's your biggest fear now
what do you worry about at this point of
your life
getting old
being in a wheelchair
having a [__] piss bag or a [__]
[__] bag
[__] not being able to take care of
myself I don't want to live like that
I'd rather die
I don't want to live like that
I gotta I'm not bragging or nothing
but I got a [__] horse dick and I
charge for this dick extra large
but
I don't want I don't want to be trying
to get an obituary no diaper on [__]
that
you've been in love before
yep
I just know I love
always picked the wrong ones
I always pick the chicks that don't
appreciate what I do for them
well mama won't mama get
I'm a hustler I'm a man I'm gonna make
sure she got clothes food if she got a
drug problem drugs I'll make sure she
gets so much dope that she don't want no
dope
but again what I do for her she don't
appreciate and so when she's being
disrespectful but she won't listen to me
or talk over me when I'm trying to talk
we're not communicating that's not how
you communicate you talking
I listen I talk you listen
but they don't never they don't ever
want to do that they want to just run
their mouth and you can't learn nothing
when you run in your mouth
and knowledge is power
and they don't ever hear what I'm saying
to them
it's sad
because I want to have forgiveness I
want to show him love but
they don't deserve it they don't earn it
so [__] them
did your life gotten easier like at 2023
or then it was in the back back like 20
years ago or even before that I won't go
to work no more I got my social security
but it ain't easier I mean
Bill's got to be paid
food got to be bought and cooked
the dope's not as good as it was
no the dope's pretty good right now
there's some creamy [__] but
it's like
now
I do more when I'm tired
my heart asleep
now the food tastes funny
when I'm getting high to where I don't
even want to eat when I'm getting I'm
usually like 460 pounds I'm a big dude
but
you know
living this lifestyle it wears on you
three or four days no sleep
you start thinking things that ain't
real seeing [__] that ain't real
but you got to be honest with yourself
when you're a man you have integrity
there's a a certain level you have to
uphold no amount of money
or drugs will make me compromise my
integrity
I look myself in the face every day
and if I can't look myself in the face
then I'm not really being a man I'm not
being true to myself
so
yeah sometimes that gets harder
you have kids about five daughters
my youngest daughter is five years old
and they're being raised by by who
I've got four baby Molly
and
so far
they've been good Babies Mamas
I just can't stand them
they're not they're not working girls my
daughter is a happy my
last baby's mama was a working girl I
took her off the blade
she wasn't doing very well
so I I saved her but after I saved her
he started getting her hair and nails
done and makeup and all of that stuff
she started getting more attention from
the
the guys on the Block and I kept telling
that you can't speak to everybody
because you're out of pocket a pimples
I'll snatch you up
and she didn't believe it she got
kidnapped but I paid for her and I got
her back
and then she got pregnant
and she wanted to be a school teacher so
I helped to get through school and
you know one thing led to another and
the result was my daughter she's
beautiful I love her
and she's smart
she's already in the first grade
she'll be in the second grade when she
turns six
and you're just working out you're in
your kids lives oh yeah
I'll have to be
without me they'd be vulnerable out
there in the streets because they fall
in love with a dude like their daddy
how do you teach them to go after a guy
who's not like you
it's hard
I don't I just teach them how to protect
themselves and I teach them how to play
chess
make your next move your best move
because it might be the only move you
got
always stay a few moves ahead that's how
you win yeah but a girl's father becomes
almost like the
oh yeah the model yeah
I'm always honest with them
I ain't no good
and I tell them the truth
and pretty much they
listen to me
the older ones
I don't know I don't like their
boyfriends but most of the time I don't
like their boyfriends because they're
like me
you can tell your kid do as I say not as
I do
but that doesn't really work
always give a child the opportunity to
choose
not out of ten times if you raise them
right they'll choose right you know
discipline is a very specific thing you
know you can train your child like you
train an animal
you make the right decision you get a
reward you make the wrong decision you
get a consequence but you have to choose
if you choose wrong and you get punished
that's what's up
if you choose right I'm always you know
give you Kudos and reward you the best I
can
I show them love they know they're loved
you know they can't do no wrong in my
eyes my daughters walk all over me
truly their mothers that's why I leave
did you ever think about doing anything
other than being in the streets
when you were a kid all the time what
would you dream about
I wanted to be Spider-Man
I didn't want to be a hero
but heroes are broke
they don't make no [__] money
[Applause]
they're always getting beat up for
nothing
they don't get no healing time
they can't kill the bad guy
not at Amy
no regrets
no regrets I think I was about
39 when I stopped having nightmares
I used to have nightmares all the time
about what
well when I got quoted
I was living in a park bench
in New York winter you know when you
little kids in New York you go to school
you see people sitting on a stoop
like this
blue
they're dead
is brutal in New York
you got to have a snow suit some long
underwear some insulated boots some
insulated socks you learn Isotoner real
quick yeah and so
when my parents put me out I thought I'm
gonna freeze to death
my friend his father was a boss a real
boss not like out here these West Coast
guys they say they were boss they ain't
no [__] boys number one you can't
call yourself a boss if you ain't got no
employees number two you can't call
yourself a boss if you don't take care
of your employees in New York when a guy
says he's a boss if you need groceries
he's got a grocery store if you need a
car he's got a car dealership if you
need a piece of ass he's got a brothel
if you want to impress your girlfriend
he's got nice restaurants in Manhattan
and he's got a limo service that'll take
you there and the guy will know you're
coming and take your jacket and call you
sir and bow down kiss your ass and all
of that [__] you know that's a real boss
he's got a haberdashery and he's also
got a Bootery where they put your foot
in the metal thing and measure your foot
and make issues where they measure you
with the tape measure and make your
clothes and these guys are real
professionals I used to bring them to
East Bay magazine and show them the
outfits that I wanted and they would
make that outfit to fit my big ass
you know my boss was good he had a
jewelry shop we had four finger gold
rings and a Run DMC Hollow necklaces and
all of that stuff
was the best time of your life
1984.
what was going on
I was rapping
with a lot of the Bay Area rappers and
Herm Lewis and JT the bigger figure was
watching a dope money with all rap
records and giving us kilos and we was
famous First Street Third Street Alabama
Hunters Point East Oakland Berkeley
Frisco and like we would go places and
people would know us
people would like us one time we did a
concert and on our way out
the crowd ripped our clothes off we got
to the car we didn't have a car keys
because we didn't have no [__] pants
on
yeah it was it was a good time
heavy what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
this is deep
because I tell you about the life that I
lived
I worked for the devil for a long time
and I can tell you right now that
when it comes to
the god that created us
I'm down for him like I was down for my
set
like four flat tires
on a Cadillac
everything that happens there's no
chance there's no
there's no luck
there's no
there's no guessing or playing
everything is God's will everything
happens it's God's purpose
I'm I'm living proof of that and
that's all I can say about that I I mean
I can't prove to you
but I've been shot 24 times in my
lifetime and I'm still here
and I can give you a good race to the
corner yeah I do ten and a half flat
what's that for
uh trafficking uh
intend to distribute gang Syndicate uh
illegal Enterprise
I had 36 felony twos
I had a 210 000 worth of liquor and
cigarettes in my garage when they rated
my house
and I was getting it
and that wasn't even the best time of my
life but I was getting it
do you believe in karma
no
you call me as a [__] [__]
my first job
working for my boys
he wanted me to cut up a dead body
wrap it up in plastic
get on the train going uh Jersey
riding through New Jersey
suitcase and a luggage rack
I'm gonna get to Jersey
wasn't no
uh cameras and [__] like that back then
you just leave the suitcase in the
luggage rack and get on the train going
back to New York
and by the time they
smelled it stinking had been lost and
found for like two weeks
and then you know I didn't have no
fingerprints on record and then
I threw up
for like an hour
just looking at the bloated body and
thinking about what I had to do with it
then I started cutting on it
I threw up then too then after my
stomach was queasy and I didn't have
nothing else in my stomach to throw up
but bile I still threw up like two more
times
but I got it done
the first time was hard
but then after that it got easy
plus I was I'm a
a weirdo in that sort
I gotta think about watching the hogs
eat their hands in the head
the hands go down quick but the head's
like a jawbreaker and they just keep on
chewing it and chewing and chewing it
till it pops
and then they slurp it all up and crunch
it down and it's gone
it's a doggy dog world isn't it
just a world we created
you know if you read the Bible and I
have several times
the one thing that's consistent
throughout the Bible is no matter how
much power
how much divineness how much love God
shows us
we're still disobedient
that's that's what your natural man is
designed to do
we don't care about rules as a race we
don't care about
what's right or wrong we use that to
judge each other
but when you get on your knees of God's
feet when you're dead
he's going to ask you what were you
doing my job because nobody can judge
you but God
you know and he's going to ask you why
were you doing my job but all those
people that tell you what you were wrong
and all the people that tell you what
you're doing is a sin and blah blah blah
blah they do it too you don't think the
preachers dick gets hard when sister
Robbins walks by with their fat ass in
that tight shirt
he digging the same thing you thinking
when you look at it with that fat ass
and that tight skirt he's not thinking
about how Pious she is or how good of a
parishioner she is or how holy she is he
thinking about what he could do with her
if he had her alone in the room naked
because he's a man it's all natural it's
our natural Wednesday to do that it's
our basic human need
to gratify ourselves
and even people that are holy their
basic human need to be holy is so they
can gratify themselves
you know they feel like they're better
than somebody but I can tell you whether
they're a dumpster diver
or whether they're a millionaire
We're All God's Children Made In His
Image he loves us all the same and ain't
nobody better than nobody
and don't judge nobody
you don't know what a [__] going
through one time I was on a bus going to
school
and this lady was sitting in the back of
the bus and she was just letting her kid
bounce all around the [__] bus going
in other people's purses [__]
snatching people's ears you know and
finally somebody asked the lady what the
[__] your problem control your kid why
are you letting them going crazy like
that
and she looked at the guy and she said
today his father died
you never know who what people are going
through everybody's got a story
and most of the time
it's worse than the next guy's story but
it's still just the story it's the
culmination of who you are as a human
being
I don't feel bad for what I've done
I don't feel bad for gang banging
I don't feel bad for the [__] I didn't
knock down
if you read the Bible again all God's
chosen
they were all killers
Moses
David
Samson
killers chosen by God though
he knows what you're going to do before
you do it he understands
sometimes people go to the extreme
but it's our basic human nature
what's your greatest strength
when I got an issue
when I got a problem
I don't dwell on it
I've I figure out the solution and then
that's what I work on
I don't I don't care about spilled milk
a lot of people they're spilling milk
and they'll just keep pointing at the
spilled milk
I know chicks that have been raped and
they talk about that [__] to this day
and it happened like 40 years ago and
they still can't get over it it happened
it's over
unless you're stupid it's not gonna
happen again what are you going to do
now
what's next
what's really your goal and how are you
going to reach your goal we all have
breakdowns
but if you get caught up in your
breakdown that's where you get screwed
gotta find a solution
or you're not going to get what you want
out of life
there's only two ways to do things
the right way the way we know how to do
it the way we know how to do it's only
going to get us so far
do you figure out the right way
you're never going to get what you
really want
all right heavy thank you so much for
speaking to me
I wish you lots of luck out here